hey everyone this is Lucy and today I'm
excited to share that the tech with Lucy
channel has just crossed a hundred
thousand subscribers here on YouTube
first and foremost I just want to say a
massive thank you to all of you who have
been a part of this journey whether you
stumbled across my YouTube videos
randomly when searching for cloud
learning tips or you're a friend or
former colleague of mine who watches the
occasional video I'm very grateful for
all of your support in helping me Reach
This Milestone when I first started
creating content on YouTube I had no
idea what the journey would take me I
always thought that 100 000 subscribers
was a milestone that was very far away
and something I might never reach but
here we are two and a half years later
with one of the most incredible and
supportive Tech communities I could have
ever asked for so as a token of my
appreciation I'm giving away 20 AWS
certification vouchers to 20 subscribers
who are on the Journey of learning AWS
Cloud these vouchers are going to cost
me about two and a half thousand dollars
but I hope they hope many of you unlock
new opportunities in your career out of
the 20 vouchers 10 will be for the AWS
Cloud practitioner certificate and the
other 10 are for associate level AWS
certifications this includes the AWS
Solutions Arctic associate the developer
associate and the sysop certification to
enter this giveaway all you have to do
is follow these three steps the first
step is to make sure you subscribed to
the channel and have given this video a
like the second step is to comment below
which AWS certification voucher you'd
like and how it would help you on your
Cloud Learning Journey and finally step
number three is to sign up to my free
email newsletter called cloudbacks.ai
where every week I share bite size
insights into the world of cloud
computing and AI this giveaway is open
for three weeks and winners will be
announced on the 5th of July in the
community section of this channel now
before you go ahead and enter the
giveaway I want to share with you a
fantastic learning platform called
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning platform with thousands of
inspiring classes for anyone who loves
learning and wants to explore their
creativity and learn new skills if you
have specific skills you're trying to
learn skillshare is a great place to
start they have courses ranging from
Tech and finance to productivity video
editing and more if you're a beginner to
the cloud I'd recommend this class by
hashtag learning providing an absolute
beginner's introduction to Amazon web
services I joined skillshare to learn
more about tech and productivity and by
taking classes like these I hope to
continue building my skills the first
1000 people to use the link in the
description below will get a free one
month trial of skillshare so regardless
of whether you end up winning the
giveaway I'd highly recommend signing up
to skillshare for one month of free
access thank you skillshare for
sponsoring today's video alright best of
luck for the giveaway everyone and once
again thank you all so much for 100 000
subscribers